[cheerful reggae music]
[Paul groaning]
- [Skateboarder] It's your
feet, your feet too big.
- [Paul] It's too hot, man!
- [Miloh] This is my roommate Paul.
He's an easygoing, lovable,
fun but forgetful guy.
That's where I come in to check him.
[phone rings] Oop! That's me calling now.
- What up, baby girl?
- Ew. Where are you?
- Yeah, I'm out skating.
- Oh, OK. Well, listen, don't forget.
You're supposed to bring
home dinner tonight for us.
- Yeah.
- [Miloh] Uh, I'm broke
and Bo is definitely broke
so make sure you bring home dinner.
- Nah, I won't forget.
- And do not bring home
Cups of Noodles and tomatoes
again like you did last time,
do no do that.
- Yeah yeah yeah, don't do that again.
- I'm, yep, I'm gonna get the food
and you better make room for seconds.
- All right. See you soon.
- [Paul] Twenty-two dollars?
[cash register bell
rings] 2 dollar draft fee?
- [Miloh] Paul's gonna have
to stretch that twenty.
- Fuck!
[cheerful piano music]
[cash register bell rings]
- Hey, Paul.
- Hey Street Tim, what's going on?
- Oh, what isn't?
Did you hear the news?
Drake's running for president.
That means instead of a
Muslim we're gonna have
a rapping-happing-hab.
Tell me that's not progress.
- That's not true.
That's also offensive.
- Ah, peas and carrots.
You know, if you believe it,
you can make it so.
That's what I've learned.
That's life.
- That's good advice, man, thanks.
- So where're you headed off to?
You got any change for me?
- Ah...
- All right, it's nice talking to you.
- All right, man.
Tim!
- Yeah?
- Here's a dollar, buddy.
[cash register bell rings]
That's all I got.
- Well,
Thanks, Paul.
A whole dollar.
I'm a millionaire.
I'm a millionaire!
- You sure are, Street Tim.
You sure are.
[bicycle bell rings]
Crazy guy, ah!
- [Cyclist] Sorry!
- Why would you do that?
- How do I stop this thing?
- Come back!
Ah, now I need Obamacare.
[screams]
- Hey man.
- [Cashier Jim] Oh, hey bro.
- Can I get a Band-Aid?
- No.
They come in a box, OK?
I can't just give you one.
They're called Band-Aids,
not Band-Aid.
- Well can you give me one
from like a First Aid Kit or something?
C'mon, I know you guys
have one back there.
- No we don't.
It's a myth.
This is my shift and we
don't have a First Aid Kit.
Ye shall not pass!
- Uh, Jim.
Jim.
Jim!
What'd I tell you about that
Game of Harry Potter
Thrones stuff here, man?
No witchcraft on the shift.
Now stop scaring the customers, man.
- Sorry, Manager Larry.
- Just gimme the Band-Aids,
bro, I'll take them.
[scanner beeps] Five dollars?
[cash register bell rings]
Are you serious?
Hey, can I get the rotisserie chicken
and kale butternut squash?
Thank you.
Hey, man.
What happened to the other guy?
- Ah, he's on break so
you're stuck with me.
It's gonna be $11.07.
[cash register bell rings]
- OK...
- Hey man, this is gonna sound weird,
but do you ever give money to
a guy named Tim on the street?
- Yeah, I do.
- That's my uncle.
- No way.
Street Tim is your uncle?
- Yeah, man, as I live and breathe.
Yeah, well he kinda lost it after 'Nam,
and he likes to live on the street now
so we just kinda let him.
I go down there and check
on him every now and then,
give him something, make sure he's good.
- Wow, dude, that's awesome.
I love him, he's a good guy.
- Hey you know what?
This one's on me.
- Are you sure, man? You
don't have to do that.
- Trust me, dude, I've got this.
Oh behalf of my uncle.
- Thank you so much, you have no...
Thank you.
I'm a millionaire!
It's something Street Tim...
don't worry about it man.
Thank you.
- That's all right.
He's a cool guy.
[Bo cheers]
- OK, deuces are wild...
Hello, good evening.
- Friends?
- [Miloh] Yes?
- I have dinner.
- [Miloh] Oh no.
- OK, so, Paul,
we're no longer friends on Instagram.
Or in real life, man.
- [Paul] Yo yo, chill, chill, chill.
I'm just joking, I'm just joking, look:
Got some chicken, huh?
Wash it down with some squash?
You feel me? Some Band-Aids,
those are mine.
But everything else we can eat, though.
- Oh, the homie got a chicken,
look at that, it even got
a little handle on it.
Man, what you gonna eat though?
- I'mma eat that chicken.
- No, you can have a wing, I guess.
- You can have a wing.
- Nah, I'm a breast man.
Wait, how'd you know I want chicken?
- [Miloh] Let's eat.
I'm so proud of Paul.
Way to step up.
He didn't tell us the story
of his day until later
but it didn't matter by then
because we were full and happy.
[upbeat rap music]
[film reel rolling]
[production theme music]